Is there a better time of day to take by supplements?
Well, that depends on what it is that you're taking.
So, a better time of day to take your supplements in general,
is it's better to spread your supplements throughout the day.
So, let's say you're taking three a day of certain supplements
for most of those, it would be better if you spread them out throughout the whole day.
Sometimes, if you're taking, let's say, vitamin C to get a higher dose of vitamin C,
you watch, take it all at once.
Remember, if you take a lower dose, vitamin C, let's say 1000 milligrams,
you're absorbing maybe 500 milligrams of that,
that's going to be an oxidative therapy.
That's not always wise for a cancer patient.
If you're trying to get an oxidative therapy out of your vitamin C,
then maybe you're taking 5000 milligrams a day, 5 grams a day of vitamin C,
you'd want to take that all at once so that you absorb an oxidative dose.
But if you're taking things for just general cancer care,
general immune stimulants, general anti-inflammatories,
you take those throughout the day because all your supplements have a half-life.
So, you will, they will dissipate out of your body quite quickly.
So, and then taking digestive enzymes in HCl,
you take those only with a meal, right?
Before your meal, right with your meal or immediately after your meal.
If you're taking an oxidative approach to melatonin,
let's say you're taking high-dose melatonin, you may take that,
you know, 40 milligrams in the morning and 40 milligrams in the evening.
So, it depends on the supplement.
General supplements like general nutrition, general anti-inflammatories,
you don't want to spread those throughout the day.
And then fat-soluble supplements, it's a little bit different as well
because fat-soluble supplements you don't need to scratch through the day.
They'll store in your body and you can just take them any time during the day.
Sometimes you could hyperlone on vitamin D, per se,
and just take it once a week.
But typically I want people to take their vitamin D three with their other
fat-soluble vitamins that I tell you to take a lower dose every day.
So, it depends on the supplement that we're talking about,
on when the time of the day is better to take it.
Obviously, if you're trying to take something to try to help you sleep,
you take it in the evening, you know, so things like that.
So, it depends on what it is that the supplement that you're trying to do with the supplement.
So, that's the supplement.